The road ahead is uncertain but
the end is clear aegon will be king
he's the firstborn son of the king you will
be with your own child sooner than late
i do not wish to get married even i do not
exist above tradition and duty run error
none of it needs be this way
in truth no one's here for me
the crab feeders dug in for siege on bloodstone
while his men sabotage our fleet the matter
of the stepstones is regrettably urgent yeah
crabs will soon die on all of us we are losing
dragon
Welcome back everyone this will be my house of
the dragon episode 3 trailer video there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here so we'll break it
all down obviously a bit of a time jump because
there's a bunch of changes in the characters and
a couple new characters that you probably haven't
seen before if you're brand new to the channel
i'm doing videos for all the episodes just like
i did for the main series game of thrones be sure
to subscribe to get them all we're also doing a
giveaway for hbo mac subscriptions all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just post
all your predictions for the episode on the video
probably the two biggest things in this trailer
are the appearance of aegon ii alicent's son with
viserys the new heir quote-unquote that the realm
is talking about that vernier is really worried
about wait a minute i'm supposed to be the heir
what's going on with this new son you just had
surprise surprise rhaenys targaryen princess who
never was was totally right last episode when she
was trying to get real with her like the realm is
never going to take you seriously eventually your
father is going to marry some woman and his son by
her will become the new king so before our eyes
ronira's world is kind of slowly crashing down
around her and her father viserys is forcing
a marriage upon her i'll talk about that in a
second too because like the other big wtf thing
is the actual war of the stepstones with daemon
and corlys velaryon one of the really important
things about the war for the stepstones though as
you notice all their forces are made up of corlys'
men along with sell swords in landless adventures
that daemon winds up hiring with money given to
him by the crown that's why most of the people
running around with the sigils on them are just
the sigil of house velaryon the reason for this
is because as they said in the previous episode
the small council king viserys didn't want to get
involved officially through the crown because they
didn't want to start an all-out war with all of
essos so he was happy to support daemon's efforts
in the war with corlys velaryon but he didn't
want to involve the crown itself what they've done
though is they've kind of compressed the timeline
because when the war the step stones was being
fought it was a bunch of different battles across
a bunch of different years and it was happening
during a different time period than all the stuff
with rhaenyra aegon viserys and alicent was going
on so i think what they've done for the episode is
there's been another small time jump like not a
massive time jump but enough time for viserys to
get remarried to alicent and then for them to have
aegon him to grow to this age and her to become
pregnant with her second child the only bonus here
for rhaenyra is that her second child is a female
named helena she does wind up having two more sons
with viserys though later in the timeline you see
some of the adult versions of these characters in
some of the first trailers they released like way
back last year like this is amen targaryen he
winds up being called aymond one eye targaryen
i'll give you one guess why he's called a man one
eye i like the idea that ronira's best friend gets
remarried to her father so there's a big betrayal
to her like we saw at the end of episode two and
she has a bunch a bunch of healthy male children
with him so it looks like at the beginning of the
trailer she's still upset with her father after
that short time jump like they haven't completely
made up yet but he's trying to reason with her
about the reality of the situation like i am a
king the realm expects me to remarry and have
more heirs with this next wife anybody else who
would have been king would have been expected to
do the same thing there were a lot of jokes about
him remarrying someone so young like they made
the jest about him remarrying lena valerian who
was only 12 years old at the time like there's no
way we're going to let this happen but his way of
justifying it is saying you know what i'm going
to do i'm not going to marry this 12 year old
i'm going to marry your best friend who's about 14
or 15 years old that's better somehow one of the
other minor changes it seems like they've done on
the show is they made alison way younger so in the
books alicent is in her mid-20s when she remarries
to viserys the first and viserys the first is only
in his mid-30s but obviously in real life patty
considine is in his late 40s so viserys looks
way older than his mid-30s maybe we can just
chalk that up to him having some weird ailment
a lot of you've also wondered if he might have a
version of diabetes because his extremities are
starting to rot like that and speaking of ill
health they've actually clarified what's going
on with kragus drahar crab feeder they showed
some behind the scenes for his character he
does have gray scale so like he's slowly dying if
his mask looks familiar that is meant to be taken
from the sons of the harpy like he's wearing his
sons of the harpy mask that he's kind of reshaping
into his own costume and his main weapon here
which he's using to nail people up to feed the
crabs literally is a battle hammer we get the
voice over from otto hightower talking to his
daughter alison basically trying to reason with
her just saying that your son aegon will be king
even though she's still trying to mend things with
renera like she still wants to be friends with her
during the trailer you see her chase her down
outside like things don't have to be like this
as rhaenyra kind of runs off into the distance
one of the things they don't totally address in
the trailer but a lot of you have suspected is
that now because there are male heirs raniera's
life is potentially in danger because depending
on how devious you think the hand of the king
otto is i don't know if he was stooped to this but
theoretically if rhaenyra were not to do anything
and just to sit around and wait for viserys to
die potentially someone like otto or someone
around viserys could just kill her to clear up the
matters of succession like okay we don't have to
worry about her anymore we have a male heir let's
put him on the iron throne so not only is renera
feeling betrayed by her father and her best friend
she's also just like a little bit worried about
her life also her father is forcing her into this
eventual marriage but that's also expected to like
you would be expected to marry someone even if
you were the heir what might be happening in this
scene here is they might actually be at harrenhal
because in the background you see harwin strong
and his father lyonel strong and he's the current
lord of harrenhal so connecting some of the dots
like things do get really spicy with ronira the
other characters just in general it wouldn't be a
game of thrones prequel show if it wasn't a little
bit spicy they're forcing her into a marriage that
marriage is this person here that you see laenor
velaryon that's because her father wants to try
and mend fences with corlys velaryon because he
kind of threw him under the bus when he decided
not to marry his daughter laina valerion this is
laenor velaryon with his father corlys and daemon
targaryen during the war the stepstone so he was
busy fighting with them during the war getting to
the spiciness of it all and lionel strong here
there's a lot of like funny rumors that go on
in a song of ice and fire books rhaenyra doesn't
want to get married she's forced to marry laenor
velaryon because of this alliance that they want
to form with the family but laenor is supposed
to be kind of like a loras tyrell type of figure
so she doesn't want to get married to him and he
doesn't really want to get married to a woman
so to speak but both of them are just kind of
forced into it also when you see her run off here
you see criston cole kind of clock her as she's
running off into the woods and she gets attacked
by what looks like a wild animal it's criston cole
that winds up saving her you see them around the
campfire after this she kind of has the hots for
criston cole but he's a kingsguard he's kind of
like a brand of tarth type of figure at this point
in the story like he wants to be a good knight so
things do get a little bit spicy between the two
of them but they don't quite go to the place where
you think that they go but these two sons of hers
are supposed to be with lehner valerion they're
like the two first sons that she gives birth to
so everyone's having flashbacks to people talking
about the color of hair of the lannister children
wait a minute why aren't they brunettes
like gendry if they were robert's children
that's because they weren't robert's children they
were jaime's children so both rhaenyra and laenor
have the white hair who is their father than for
real there was a rumor recorded in the books that
said it was harwin strong who was secretly their
father and it becomes this big salacious rumor
that gets passed around court in this part of the
trailer harwin strong is also the captain of the
city watch the gold cloaks that daemon created
so when her father is telling her oh you'll be
with your own child sooner than late that's the
marriage that he's talking about to laenor and
the children that she eventually has with him that
we think that she has with him but like i said big
salacious rumors about her secretly having an
affair in the children being fathered by harwin
strong later in the trailer when they talk about
the war of the triarchy in the crabfeeder digging
in on bloodstone that's sort of like the seat of
power inside the stepstones they're trying to take
the dragons you see flying in the background
is demons dragon karaxis obviously love the
part of the trailer at the end where they yell
dragon and he starts attacking the battlefield
anytime there's a dragon in a battle it's epic the
closest comparison i would make would be to like
the field of fire they called it the loot train
battle during the main game of thrones series
but during aegon's conquest it was a similar type
of engagement where he brought balerion in the
black dread and basically burned the entire field
of opposing soldiers and they called it the field
of fire that's basically what you see caraxies do
to this field of battle here like he just lights
the entire place on fire now it's also important
to note during the main series they introduced
the scorpion but that was an ancient device that
they basically pulled out of mothballs qyburn was
like i think i found something that can fight the
dragons we haven't used it in a long time but it's
very effective so just because the targaryens had
had dragons for so long the scorpions other ways
of fighting dragons had been a thing for a long
time even back during aegon's conquest so just
having a dragon outright didn't mean you were
invincible in battle a lot of just depended on
who you were fighting and how well equipped they
were that's one of the reasons why doran wasn't
conquered during aegon's conquest because they had
methods and techniques for fighting dragons and
that was like aegon's big trump card but the whole
idea is that during the war of the stepstones
during all the different battles the triarchy's
army crabfeeder's army vastly outnumbered daemon
in corlys' army but because they had caraxes they
had the dragon it kind of balanced things out he's
gonna barbecue so many people in next week's
episode i will be interested to see though if
they do the entire war of the stepstones in just a
single episode in the other trailers you also see
a little bit of the aftermath of the battle in the
earlier trailers you see daemon walking into the
throne room viserys sitting on the iron throne
he's wearing that crown the same suit of armor
when they eventually defeated the triarchy's army
corlys crowned him king of the stepstones remember
when he was trying to sell him on the alliance at
the end of episode two he was trying to sell him
on the idea of making a name for himself that's
why daemon crowns himself king of the stepstones
and just to be clear the step stones themselves
weren't officially part of the seven kingdoms
that's why he could do something like that daemon
is the rogue prince but like he's not gonna crown
himself the king of a part of westeros that would
invite open war with the crown it'd be like going
to a completely different country and saying you
know what i'm gonna be king of this country over
here after we conquer it obviously the rest of
the realm doesn't take that too kindly like his
brother the kingsguard here don't take it too
kindly but one of the other things they're doing
with these first couple of episodes episode two
also when you see renera fly under cloud cover
and come up to dragonstone really cool scene
you see caraxie's joining the battle here and
just light everybody up we're heading to the
dance of the dragons the targaryen civil war
where a bunch of different dragon riders fought
in the air on their dragons so you have to imagine
a bunch of dragons all doing this fighting each
other at the same time on screen so as cool as the
dragons have been the last couple of episodes it's
gonna get way way crazier especially in future
seasons but i think it'll be season two before
we see a lot of the dragons fighting each other
in the air like later in season two season three
type of stuff based on the way they're charting
the episodes out the last couple of trailers
we've seen it seems like they're gonna spin up
to the actual dance of the dragons towards the
end of season one the beginning of season two
if there's anything you spotted in the trailers
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
it below in the comments i have a couple big bonus
videos planned for this week too my full episode 3
video will post next sunday just like normal and
a lot of you've also asked for me to bring back q
a videos so i might do that in the next couple of
weeks too i'll name a giveaway winner and my next
big house the dragon video everyone click here
for my full house of the dragon episode 2 video
and click here for that big house of the dragon
season 2 announcement in my top 10 wtf predictions
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!